cada día
a primera hora de la mañana se repite la
misma escena en este municipio
guatemalteco
necesitan tomar agua los perros y no hay
agua seño qué hacemos
a 10 minutos de la turística antigua
esta alde azufre como muchas otras en
los alrededores de cortes de agua
cotidianos que pueden prolongarse por
semanas quisiera uno tener el agua como
allá pero no y este panorama se tensa
aún más a medida que se acerca la semana
más importante para el turismo
guatemalteco para Semana Santa en estos
días por ejemplo se escasea más el agua
y me imagino yo como que desviaran el
agua para tal vez para la plazuela que
es la gente que hace mucho mucha venta
la alta vulnerabilidad de la región ante
el cambio climático perjudica aún más a
unos pueblos que históricamente han
contado con poca inversión en sus
infraestructuras
la producción de agua ha ido bajando es
un fenómeno y el otro fenómeno al revés
Es que la población ha ido creciendo
por su parte la municipalidad de
antigüedad descarta cualquier lógica de
privilegio del turista en detrimento de
los municipios
no el tema de las aldeas muchas veces es
por tema de fugas en algún momento puede
romperse una tubería lo cual puede pasar
aquí también en la ciudad cuando hay más
por ejemplo hay más
de turistas en las habitaciones hay más
consumo de agua muchas veces ellos lo
suplen con tienen pozos propios algunos
de los hoteles grandes la carencia de
una legislación así como una red de
acueducto que no sigue el ritmo del
crecimiento demográfico son en la
opinión de la población las causantes de
la escasez de agua en un país rico en
recursos hídricos como Guatemala